[Music]
as the u.n climate conference gets
underway in scotland we are taking a
look at the effect of travel on the
planet there's a growing interest in
seeing places that are being
dramatically altered already by global
warming and what's being called last
chance tourism even before the pandemic
forbes said this was one of the top
trends in travel but it's also having
its own impact on the environment then
tracy traveled to iceland one of the
many locations all around the world
seeing an increase in visitors
it's crazy this country is beautiful in
this lagoon on the southern coast of
iceland giant chunks of ice once part of
a massive glacier gently float away into
the north atlantic ocean
definitely sad but it's
very grateful to be able to you know
look at this stuff while i still can we
ran into sharad sivamani from new york
he brought his parents here to see this
frozen beauty we wanted to get a chance
to look at it before you know some of it
melts away but it's absolutely striking
in recent years the trio has visited
patagonia and a desert in bolivia both
are threatened by climate change have
you actually heard that phrase although
chiron hadn't heard the term last chance
tourism it sounds like that's what
you've been doing that's the rationale
for sure it's really kind of sad if you
put it that way but that i guess that's
what we're doing like while we still can
while it's still here go take a look
a lot of people are now rushing to
places such as the great barrier reef in
australia rapidly dying from coral
bleaching the shrinking dead sea in
israel and the melting ice cap of mount
kilimanjaro
after a 92 percent increase in tourism
on the galapagos islands off ecuador the
united nations now says tourism itself
is one of the main threats to the
island's habitat
it is a challenge that we need to fix
iceland's minister of the environment
says tourism in his country was booming
before kovit
increasing nearly 40 percent in some
years
topping 2 million annual visitors which
is more than four times the population
of the entire country
iceland is a beautiful country and we
also have a responsibility to protect
our nature there is no getting around
the fact that all those people coming to
iceland
are actually making the climate issue
worse by flying i absolutely agree with
you we are an island in the middle of
the north atlantic and most of the
people come with airplanes
mile for mile air travel is the most
damaging form of transportation for the
planet just one round-trip transatlantic
flight emits twice as much
planet-warming carbon dioxide emissions
per person as driving the family car for
an entire year
if people are coming here because they
want to see something that is
disappearing
it is our responsibility to tell people
why and what they can do to prevent it
and we have a lot of opportunities to do
so here in iceland especially with the
receding glaciers the tourists must love
this
oh man yeah they are definitely amazed
the tourist boom turned hawker einerson
into a tour guide he now spends his days
out on the glaciers and inside these ice
caves which funnel all the water from
the melting ice sheets out to sea
his business glacier adventures has
replaced the old family farm
so this was a cow farm
yeah just three years ago they're used
to milk up to 34 cows here every day
twice a day is this better than milk and
cows it's different we tell them a joke
that now we milk tourists instead of
cows
do they get a kick out of that yeah yeah
of course
but hawker is serious about making sure
that when tourists like alyssa zimmerman
from chicago come here they get more
than just a stunning selfie you want to
be able to kind of witness it with your
own eyes instead of reading about it in
a book or hearing about what was
hawker says his job is to make visitors
get a deeper appreciation for how
quickly the scenery in those photos is
now changing we are able to influence
them
in a good way like open their minds and
sent them home with
some thoughts so that's kind of how i
see it as an opportunity
turning a last chance into a first step
in better understanding our changing
planet
for cbs morning's ben tracy iceland
the milking tourist joke was just a joke
because i could see people going ah okay
because he clearly loves his country
yeah really loves the country wants us
to come and see it and have a good time
when we're there doesn't make me want to
go yeah i'd love to go actually uh you
know you could also stay here at home
glacier national park uh in america also
receding glaciers but lance last chance
tourism melting glaciers it kind of
feels like you're visiting a relative
dying of old age
yeah because you're looking at something
that's disappearing right in front of
you it's somewhat sad i hope it's
something that's us that we need to do
more to say this 100 sad yeah